the go programming language can be used
to deploy serverless stacks to aws in
this course akil sharma will teach you
how to code and deploy a complete
serverless stack with basic crud
functions on aws using go this it's a
complete serverless stack
right so you're using dynamodb
serverless you're using lambda
serverless again
and then we'll be using api gateway
again serverless now api gateway helps
us
enables anybody across the world to
interact with our lambda function right
so we'll be deploying all these three
things
uh
from the aws console right we'll be
using the aws console and then we'll
make settings for all these three things
and we'll deploy all of this
and anybody across
the world can use our lambda function so
this is more like a real world scenario
so i'm in my terminal now and you don't
really have to keep this project in your
go root because since golang 1.12
anyways they had you know go mod in it
which we're going to do anyways out here
go modern it takes care of everything i
mean you don't have to really
do anything manually all right so here
we'll say
we will make a directory first we'll say
go
serverless
and yt all right and we'll cd into this
go serverless stack yt for yt is
basically youtube i'm making this
project for youtube specifically all
right and here i'll say
go mod in it
and which is basically github
dot com
slash akil
slash go
serverless yt
so that's my project it's initialized go
mod for me go mod is basically like my
package.json file if you're from a
javascript background
it'll have all my dependencies for me
you know easily listed out
so
now what i can do is i can just open
this project up and
code editor which is vs code in my case
um just as a pointer
right i'm using
windows inside windows i'm i have
something called as wsl inside that i'm
using ubuntu 20.04 and i use multiple
different versions of ubuntu right stand
this for this particular video i'm using
google 2.04 and in my ubuntu 20.04 uh
instance i have vs code setup all right
now uh i don't want to install a lot of
extensions uh for golang because i know
when i'll start typing uh i'll start
writing a lot of code i'll make some
mistakes right with golang i'll make
some mistakes but i will fix them so
don't worry i don't have extensions
because i don't want to like start you
know ballooning up my instance because
this is just one of the instances that i
use uh on my windows pc for ubuntu i
have
like 10 15 different versions of ubuntu
right
so
uh if you're new to golang by the way
main.go file is your main
file right in the project
and this is how you start the main.co
file you say package main and you say
import and because you'll import some
packages right not everything you'll
have
inside golang golang is very modular uh
you have to install a lot of external
packages and a lot of uh you know
packages that come with golang you have
to specifically tell that you know i
need this package from golang
and uh so the
the third party packages that we'll be
using will be mostly around
lambda all right so we'll talk about
them in a while and then uh
the most important thing here will
always be funk main because that's your
entry point into the program right the
funk main
uh now before i start writing anything
in main.gofile what i'll do is i'll just
try and create
like a very simple
project structure
i need the build folder right because
i'm going to keep my build of this
entire project in my build folder and
that's i'm going to zip it up and then
i'm going to keep take that zip file to
my lambda uh sorry my aws lambda console
all right so that's why i need the build
folder
and i need my cmd folder because that's
where i usually keep my main.gov sorry
not in the
build but in my cmd folder i use keep my
main.co file
all right
and then you'll have a package folder
so uh if you've worked with golang
before this is like the very standard
kind of uh structure right nothing
nothing new so package will as you
already know will have handlers
right handlers to handle the apis
and then you'll have i'll have a
folder for user
i'll explain to you why i'm doing that
and then i'll have a very simple
validation function so i'll keep that in
a folder called validator sorry daters
sorry
uh that's it yeah so in validators i
will have just one little file
of badly like
five six lines of code i think
it's just going to be as email valid
just to check if my email is valid for
the user
and here in my user
i'll have a file called user.go
all right in my handlers that's where my
main logic resides so this is a very
short very small project handlers i'll
just have two files i'll have
api response dot go because i need this
file for my api gateway i'll
build it you'll understand what it is
and then it's handlers.go
right
now my user.go file is kind of
a combination of my models
and my
almost like my controllers as well you
know so i have handlers
but you know user.go file will have a
lot of code which kind of which talks to
my database all right directly talks to
my database so i'll have those models
like those structs as well at the same
time i'll have model functions uh those
uh sorry database functions at the same
time i'll head over to your main.go
and funk main i think what l2 is
i'll start with this place right i'll
say os dot
get environment
pws region so aws region is very
important because that's where your uh
lambda will go and sit right so with aws
if if you've worked with aws a lot you
know that it has different regions right
so my particular aws is configured with
india which is asia pacific south once
uh if you have been using aws cli and
it's set up it's uh it'll be amazing uh
otherwise also i don't think you should
have a problem
right
but just try and
uh just try and set up aws here it's
very easy just a five minute process and
it'll be very simple for you to follow
along with all of my other videos as
well because uh in my other videos it's
a prerequisite
so um
how do you create a session
so you'll say session dot new session
now
if i'm calling this os
here right so i need to have os here
that's the package right and if i'm
calling session here session is
something that aws lambda gives me aws
gives me sorry so i'll say github.com
now i'm looking at the documentation for
the aws packages at the same time you
can do that otherwise
in case you're you're the type of person
who wants to like know uh exactly which
package you are installing because i am
that type of person i don't want to
install any extra packages right so if
you like me you you might want to open
up um just like i've done you might want
to open up the
aws sdk it's called so i'll say aws aws
sdk for go you want to you want to open
up the uh the documentation
and here you'll see it will be slash
session
all right
and to create the new
session you'll see
aws dot
config
and the bracket
which will be curly braces bracket
you'll say region
aws dot
string
inside that you'll pass the region
all right
all right
and then
as you know with all everything to do
with golang whenever we haven't
uh we get two things usually right we
get the thing that we're looking for
which is the aws session which will come
from the session function
right sorry the new session function
which is a part of the session uh
package that we have here and uh we get
the error so
with golang you have to like keep uh
handling errors and this is a very neat
and clean way of handling errors because
at every stage you know where there is
coming from and you can handle it there
itself so if there's an error just
return all right
and i want to create a variable called
dyna client which for my dynamodb
and
dot
new
and
uh how do you create a new client you'll
say aws session
perfect which you've just created out
here
so you've created the session and then
you'll say lambda dot lambda.start
and handler
so this you may not understand right now
not a problem
so firstly we want dynamodb how do you
get dynamodb you get it like this it'll
say github.com slash aws slash aws
sdk go slash service slash
dynamo
tv
all right
so you have session you have dynamodb
and
you want aws itself in the first place
so you'll say github.com
slash aws
sdk go slash eight plus
to get this lambda function
uh sorry the lambda package which has
the start function
you need the start function
what you'll do is you'll say github
dot com
slash aws aws
lambda go slash
lambda
cool
so far so good that's what i needed you
know
and
i need something called as the handler
which we'll talk about in a while
okay
for now
i'm creating a constant
called table name
stable name is
lambda user i'll say lambda in go user
and
now it's time to create my handler which
is this basically
so i'm passing my handler there in my
handler what i'm doing is
i have a request
basically i accept some things right in
this function and i return some things
and it has some definition
so what does it accept except accepts
events dot
api
gateway
proxy
request so you're wondering what's
events right so events is basically what
golang lambda will give us so
i'll come here
and
i'll say
github.com
slash aws aws
lambda go
slash
events perfect
and
the other thing that this accepts is
star events dot api
okay to a
proxy response
sorry i meant that this it accepts a
request
returns a response
i'm not sure what i said actually before
that what i'm trying to say here is that
you know this is a function that accepts
something and it turns something
obviously accepts a request obviously
returns a response right no complication
there
that's what you wanted to do
and what you'll do here is you'll switch
with the
http method so you'll say switch
we'll say request dot
http
method
so what are the htm methods that you
have you have get post put and delete
that's all you have so for
uh every single
different
uh hb method we want to call a different
function
how do you do that so you'll say switch
sorry we've already switched right we've
already switched
it's like um
it's 8 30 here so i'm kind of sleepy
i usually get sleepy at 11 pm but
somehow today i'm sleepy earlier because
i woke up really early
i've joined this martial arts class that
that you know
gets me to wake up at 5 00 am these days
so
so you'll have something called as
handlers
right and where will those handlers come
in from it's basically these handlers
that you want to
import so which are basically your own
uh creation here you know the handlers
are your own creations you'll say
github.com
[Music]
handlers
cool so you're saying to golang is that
uh this is my project github.com slash
eclipse go go serverless yt
inside there i have a folder called
package instead of i have a
package called handlers right
and handlers the file
uh on top of that file will say package
handlers and it belongs to the handlers
folder then
golang understands okay that this is
what we're talking about all right
that's the format i mean the the folder
name and the package name have to be the
same just letting you know in case you
didn't know that i mean
um
i mean i'm pretty sure you knew that but
i'm just making sure right so you have
request table name and dinar client
right so you send this to this function
called handlers.getuser which we'll work
on in a while
so that was your case get now you have
more cases right you have depending on
the http method so you have post
you will have
put
and you'll have
delete
for
post you'll set it on
handlers.create
user again you'll pass request comma
table name
comma dyna client
for put you'll pass return
handlers dot
update user request comma sorry
request comma
table name comma dyna client
and for delete we'll just do handlers
dot
delete
user
and same things you'll pass the same
things comma dyna client
and after delete you will just
give it a default
if you work with case search and case
statements you obviously know there's a
default right and try to keep the
identity same
it won't affect it but just it's just a
good habit you know
i mean i don't do it many times but you
know
i
try to do it
these days all right
so by default you want to call this
function called unhandled
method
which is again in your handlers
file or handlers package
and this is the entire picture i mean uh
i don't think we're missing anything we
have the os package down here we have
events lambda aws session dynamodb
yeah there's one more package actually
if you look at the aws sdk
document
then you want to import
sdk go slash
service slash
dynamodb slash
panama
tvi face
just keep these packages
and what i think we should do is we
should just say go mod diary
so i'll get us all the package that
we've just uh talked about
and usually like many times i do this at
the end of the
end of the video
right but this time i'm just doing it
beforehand itself because many people
they can start freaking out hey you're
installing all these packages if not
you've not run the command go my go mod
id or you're making so many mistakes man
while typing why don't you install some
extensions i've explained to you why i
don't why i don't install extensions
right
so so with golang i mean what happens is
that you know we usually come from
javascript kind of a background and then
we think that oh you know if you're
making all these mistakes then the
complete program will crash and
it will be difficult to solve it but
with golang golang is very different
from other programming languages right
make as many mistakes as you want
and once you run the program golang will
really handle everything for you it will
tell you which line what's the problem
it's quite intelligent
right it's not like your regular uh
other programming languages like
javascript
so here one thing that we missed out was
to create the dyna client in the first
place right so then a client has in the
variable
and the defining the type of variable
the data client is so what type of dynam
uh there it will be
that's where we'll use this
rmdb i face right we'll say dot dynamo
thermo tv
api
just make sure you get this right all
right
so that's your main file your main file
is complete
and
now you want to uh start handling
handlers so here so since these two
files belong to the same folder called
handlers we wanted to both to be
package handlers
right so we'll say
package
handlers
right that's clear till now i'm hoping
and
after writing the package you say import
and then you have your
main func you know for in this case this
the main function of this uh file is
called
api response
accepts some things
return some things and it has a function
definition
what does it accept except status
which is end
and
which has an interface
what does it
return it returns
event start
api gateway proxy response
comma error
right
for importing you will say encoding
slash
json
and github.com
slash aws
slash
address lambda go
slash events
okay
all we're doing with this is basically
defining
the response right so
we'll say response is equal to
event start
api gateway response
and the response you're just setting the
headers
pretty standard
because the way we're going to set up
these headers
are something that you've already seen
so many times which is basically content
type and application json so we're
saying that
we're returning
json from
our lambda function
right nothing
uh out of the ordinary so we'll say
response dot
status code
is equal to status
and
so i will be basically your like 400 for
300 uh something like that
and then you'll say string body comma
json.marshall
sorry so you uh if you've been with
golang you already know what smartlink
and d marshalling unmarshalling sorry is
golang doesn't understand
json on its own so it needs the help of
json marshalling
which is part of this encoding slash
json package
and
so whenever you send some json from
postman into
postman or maybe terminal wherever you
send some uh json
uh it basically we we want uh golang to
understand it also and also the
information that golang produces for it
to become json uh
and send it as a response that also
needs uh you know help uh go like it's
helpful with both so that's why it's
called mastering and muscling there are
hundreds of videos about it
on youtube you can check it out nothing
fancy or nothing uh complicated
you have to do that in uh you know
almost all the other languages right
which are not javascript which is like
basically java and python all these
languages you have to do something like
that right
because any language that's not
javascript does not understand json by
default because json is javascript
object notation
so this is your api response dot go all
right that's it i mean there's nothing
much going on here in this file
but
the other file in handler's package
handlers this is where we're going to
spend some time because
obviously there will be a lot going on
here right
so the main functions that
usually will be there will be
based on our main.go file so main.go
file requires get user function create
user update user delete user and unlock
method unhandled method sorry so these
are the functions that obviously that
you need to create right so you'll say
get user
and
you will say create user
you will say update user and delete
users func
update user
and delete user
all right so here the last function that
we want to keep here
is
unhandled method
right so
for let's say if somebody uh uses the
patch method because you're handling
get post put delete if somebody uses
batch then we'll say that hey
it's not handled right so we'll say
unhandle method
accept some things return some things
and has a
function definition
all right so this is uh in general this
is how your
handles file is going to be like
and
what we can do is we can work on our is
email validated uh valid file
so we'll say package validators
and there's a package that you get with
golang it's called regular expressions
and we're just creating a simple
function
where we're just saying if the email is
valid or not
right really simple
all it does is accepts
an email string
and returns a boolean like yeah true or
false
we'll take a variable called rx email
we'll use the reg expression regular
expression package
and if you look at the regular
expression documentation like i have in
front of me go to the golang official
documentation and check out the regular
expression package
i i highly recommend you to open it if
you want because that's what i've done
out here in my other screen
we'll use
the
function called must compile
and i'm going to copy and paste a
regular expression string here
you don't really need to understand what
this does you just get it directly from
the
documentation but if you really want to
know basically uh you're just checking
if you know the numbers are between a to
z a to z uh and zero to nine that kind
of stuff right that's all it's doing and
it's also checking for at symbol
right
that means obviously if it's an email it
needs to have an ad right
so those kind of things just basic email
validation check is happening out there
do check out the regular expression
document if you want to really
understand what this regular expression
does all right
uh but if you want to save time just
copy and paste it like i did just did
and
now we want to check the length of email
if email if length of email is less than
three or
length of email
is more than 254
or
our rx email
variable
dot mat string
then you'll just return false
right so this returns either true or
false
if these conditions are not met
then you return false otherwise you
return
true that means everything is fine and
email is valid right obviously if this
is not uh proper it's not working
properly if uh length is more length is
less
we'll say the email is not valid
otherwise
we'll say it's true you can change these
numbers as you want but i've kept them
to be 3 and 254 all right you can change
it on your taste
so uh now we'll go to our user.go file
and we'll just add a very ten thousand
feet level i'll just set up this file
now what i want uh should happen is that
from my handlers
like the main control you know with that
will go to the main file
to our uh you know to this function
basically and this function is calling
the get user function and create user
function update user and all these
functions are as you know mentioned in
the handlers right and from the handlers
from the handlers you will call the
functions in your user.go file and these
functions will be actually the database
functions that actually talk to the
database right
so every function that you have here
except for the unhandled method because
it doesn't do much uh these four crud
functions that we have they have an
equivalent function in your user.com
file a complete like one is to one
function in your user.go file that talks
to the database all right so let's do
that let's create those functions so
firstly as you know when we start off a
file
we import some things and then
here i'll also want to find some
variables uh some errors that i want to
define
so the functions that i want to have
here in my user.go file which will have
one is to one relationship with these
four functions
the first function will be
called i'll call it
fetch
user
so that means is
my get user function gets called in my
handlers and this function will call in
my user.go file the fetch user function
which directly gets
the user from the database itself the
database in this case being dynamodb
right
so it accepts some things returns
something then it has a function
definition simple
the second function that i want to have
is for
getting multiple users actually so i'll
say
funk
fetch
users
similarly it'll look very similar
then i want to have
a create function
so i'll have create user
and then
it has update user
okay you just have to keep looking here
and then creating these functions
and then you have the last one is delete
user right so you'll come here
right if it doesn't get deleted then you
don't have to return anything specific
so especially you can just return an
error that's why
from the return here is just an error
right
and
uh
that's about it so we have one is to one
functions all of these but one extra
function is there which is fetch users
all right so we'll see where to get
where to use it
so from a ten thousand feet perspective
this is your user.google file and this
is your handler's file so what we'll do
is we'll start working on our handles
function and then at the same time we'll
start working on our
user.go functions
and here you'll obviously up import some
things right
um
the first thing that i need is net slash
http
then i need my lambda event so i'll say
github.com
aws
lambda go slash events now it's possible
that i'm importing these but you're not
understanding why i'm importing these so
you might get confused so
uh now there are two ways to do it one
is when i'm actually writing the code
and then i use this events
packet somewhere and then i come and
come up and you know import it or i know
um you know which ones i need so i'll
just import them right in the beginning
itself so that i can use them later on
so i'm just doing this so try not to get
confused because we'll actually be using
these packages in just like two three
minutes
don't worry you know why we're importing
them where will we use it so
please be patient
slash aws
right so these are the same packages
that we've already used in our main.co
file
and we'll say github.com slash aws
slashing plus
okay go slash service slash
turnover db slash dynamo tv i face
[Applause]
great
one thing that i need here
because i would want to call these
functions like i told you right i won't
call these functions so that's why
i want to import this user package in my
handlers file how would i do that i
would say github
dot com slash akil slash
go
serverless
yt
slash
package slash user
so inside package
inside the user package
we've imported it here
all right
and then before i get started these
functions i want to define a very a
variable called error
method not
allowed
is equal to method not
allowed
and
why do i need to create this
because
firstly we will be working on this
function unhandled method right so
that's why we want to call this function
so here
this returns an
event
api gateway event so it will say
api gateway proxy response comma error
right so we'll just send response from
here
or we'll just send an error and here
you'll say return api response the
response that you want to send
is http dot
when we say http we are talking about
the http package net http package all
right status
method
not
allowed comma
header method not load which we have
just defined
together right
that's what we're saying so we're saying
that
uh we have uh you know something for get
post button delete but we don't have
something for patch so patch or any
other method that somebody
plans to use
so if you get something like that like
an unhandled handle method so you'll
send a response saying that hey
this method is not allowed
all right
and i want to create
another variable
but it's actually a struct right so it's
an error body
and i'll be using it
a lot so just bear with me as to why i'm
creating it
this struct
has a variable called error message
chat string
error comma
commit
empty
cool
now for your get user
[Music]
you have
you accept something and you turn
something here
for a get user what do you accept what
do you what does the function get you
get a request right from postman the
request that you get is
uh
part of this events packet so you'll say
event start
api gateway request
comma table name which is string
comma
dyna client
dot
dynamo
db api
and what is return
it returns a response obviously so we'll
say events
dot api gateway proxy response
comma error
straightforward
and actually
this
these two things right what it's going
to accept and what's going to
return
is going to be used by all of the
functions so what you'll do is you just
copy and you'll just paste it here
for create user
for update user as well
and
for delete user as well
awesome
so we've done a lot of heavy lifting
now we want to start working on the
function definitions for these all these
functions
right so the first thing that you'll say
is email
request dot
query
string parameters
emails
so if you've
guessed what's happening here is you
want to get the user but by using the
email id of that user
so from a request you'll have your query
string parameters which we'll pass as
email
and that we're going to capture in a
variable called email
and then we'll check
the length so we'll say if length
of email is greater than zero
then you'll get a single user so you'll
say user dot
fetch user which we've just created
together right we've not created the
definition but you know which function
i'm talking about it's in my user
uh package which i've been imported here
already
so fetch user is going to take the email
table name and die in a client
and i'm going to capture this in
the result
or they're going there's going to be an
error and if there's an error i'll
handle the errors i'll say if error not
equal to nil
return
api response
http dot
status bad request
comma
error body
so error body is the stuck that i've
already defined and in error body i want
to pass
aws dot
string
error dot
error
[Music]
and otherwise you'll see hdp dot
everything is okay so we'll say status
okay
if everything goes well
and you'll pass the result from this
function
now if
if you want
multiple users
you'll say user dot
fetch users
same thing table name
and a client
and
what you'll do is you'll again use
result and error to capture the values
coming from this function
and if there's an error and you'll check
if error is not equal to nil you'll
return the api response
saying http dot status pad request
because there's an error right
and you'll send the error body just like
we did earlier error body is the struct
that we've already defined
that's the error body that we are
sending which is basically json
and here the error body
uh inside that we're going to
uh send you're going to send aws.string
header dot
error
got it
but if everything went well and there
was no error then we're going to return
api response
and http dot
status okay
comma result
so basically that's your get user
now what you can do is we can
work on our fetch user and fetch users
both of these functions in our user.go
file or we can work on our create user
function in our handlers so i think i'll
do the former
i'll work on fetch users and
i'll work on fetch user let me just
check if everything is recording yes
everything is recording perfectly
and i just i need to keep making sure
otherwise you know i end up making a
long video when nothing has recorded and
that leads to a big problem
all right so before i do anything with
[Music]
users
i want to first create a user right so
like i said this file is a mix of that
model file that you usually create where
you define the struct of how the user is
going to look like so i'll say user
struct
email now since this user struct is
small and we don't have multiple structs
like if this was
a um
e-commerce for example then you would
have had users and orders and you know
all those different like products and so
many different structs right so you'd
have to have like a models separate
models folder for all these different
models
and then you'll have you'd have uh you
know database um functions separately
and controllers or something like that
right
but since we don't have that we have a
very small project which which just has
users and users all itself it's a very
small struct because you just have
email first name and last name
you don't have too much here right you
can
combine controllers and models into the
same file
now email is going to be
a string
which is going to say json
and you say like this json email because
for golang's purposes it will be emailed
with a capital e whereas when json where
it's stored
uh it's going to be emailed with a small
e so you need to tell golang that you
know there are two versions of it one
the json version the another here's the
version that golang understands because
golang does not understand
json as i've already told you so that's
why we'll also have to use some
marshalling and unmarshalling
uh to get it to understand
and interact with json all right so
you'll have first name and last name
and then what we'll do is we'll create
our fetch user function
what does it accept so if you actually
go to handlers you'll see the fetch user
function
accepts email table name dyna client so
you'll say here email
and table name which is string
and your dyna client which is of type
you already know then
dbi face dot
dynamodb api
and it just returns a user
obviously i mean you fetch user you
return that particular user or you don't
error if nothing works out
you define a variable called input
and it's of type dynamodb dot
get
item
input
so we'll have to define the key based on
which our uh database function will run
to find that particular user and you
already know that the user will be found
from the database based on the email id
so we take an email id we take an email
id and then we want to find the user
that's associated with that email id all
right so
straightforward
we'll say dynamodb dot attribute value
and
we're going to say email because we want
to run a query on email so email is
equal to
s is equal to aws.string
dot
sorry inside that bracket will pass
email now the string
is a function that is given to us by aws
package aws packet is something that
we'll have to import out here all right
and similarly with the dyno db so we'll
have to also import the dynamodb package
so come here on your import and uh
firstly called encoding
json because like i told you golang does
not instant json by default so you need
uh encoding slash json package to uh
use the marshalling and unmarshaling
functions and i need the errors package
also
then i want to
get my hands on
the events
i'll be using it soon
to send responses and
the usual ones uh as you can see i need
dynamdb and i need aws so let's
get those ones
so i'll say aws slash aws
sdk
go slash aws
and i'll say github.com aws slash aws
sdk go slash
dynamo tv
and what i'll also do i'll also get this
particular package
um
yeah let me do that for now
so i'll say
aws
github.com
hd case
go
slash service slash
dynamo
db slash
dynamodb
i face
all right
now coming
uh here
you've already
passed this and
after this bracket
you need to specify the table name in
which this
function is going to run so
we'll use the uw string function again
to pass the table name
and after this bracket
you want to use your dyna client to
finally
start getting the item
input is this basically the query that
you created right and get item is the
function that you get in a client
and
you'll capture that in result and error
so
standard practice if there's an error
we'll have to return the error so we'll
return nil for the value and
we'll return errors dot new
error
failed to
fetch
record
so um
you must be wondering where is where
does this error come from you've
probably never seen this error right
because this is a new error that i've
created on my own
how can i create my own errors i can
create my own errors like this so error
fail to fetch record
is equal to
fail to fetch
record
and similarly i can define any errors
that i want in this variable
defined as a variable right
so you've uh you know created a query
very similar to mongodb right you've
created a query based on the email
because you want to search for that
email so that you can retrieve the user
and you've run the function get in get
item for dynamodb
and you've passed the query to it and
you've received that in something called
as result or you received an error so if
there's an error you handle the error
but if the result is fine and nothing
really happened then you would do
something right
but before that
we'll create a variable called item and
it'll be basically a new user
and here you'll say error is equal to
dynamo
db attribute
dot on marshall map
okay so
dynamodb attribute is another uh by the
way if you have not opened up the nanodb
uh and aws sdk go documentation do that
because i have it open on my other
screen you can do that as well and then
everything will make a lot more sense
because these are actual packages inside
that main package right
so i'm using those and once you go
through the recommendation you'll
understand
where to use
which one
or you or if you really don't care about
that you can just keep following along
with what i'm doing but i just recommend
that you just read it because
you know everything will make more sense
here i need
this package right then i'm going to be
attribute
this is helping me and marshalling the
user
so first let me write the whole code
so i'll say result sorry not here
here i'll put a bracket will say result
dot
[Music]
item comma
item
and this error if this error is not
equal to nil
what you want to do
we want to return nil comma errors dot
new
error
failed
to
on
marshall
record
so you must be wondering what's
happening here right
so when you get the
data from your dynamodb using the get
item function into result
you want to unmarshal that into an
actual user
which the front end can understand
as a json basically
so you use the user struct
and you uh you know
take that in a variable called item
right so item is basically um
a variable of type user
and then
you know you want the data that's coming
from your result dot item you want that
to be unmarshaled and brought into item
so that
now whatever has come as uh json
uh becomes
uh you know the type
which is user which is understood by
golang but and it's captured in a
variable called item
right
um
so i've tried to explain to you every
single line in case you don't understand
it do check out what's marshalling and
unmarshalling all right
and if you have any error like if you
still have any confusions you can just
put it in the comments below
i'll sort it out for you but it's
nothing very difficult right you're just
um taking what's coming from nanobb the
json and you're unmarking it to uh make
it into a struct
right
which is of type user which has email
first name last name something that can
be understood by golang and you're
capturing that in a variable called item
which is obviously of type user right
that's stuck that we have defined
this is standard practice i do this in
all my other videos as well in case
you're new to this channel i have
hundreds of videos on golang you can
check all of them out
like literally hundreds of videos on go
like right check them out build projects
with me
and you'll understand very everything
very easily
so if everything went well
if there was an error obviously you sent
nil and you sent the errors but if
everything went well you would return
the item and then you will return nil
for the error
now you'd want to also work on the fetch
users function the plural fetch users
function
how do you do that you
are passing table name there
as you can see here you're passing table
name and nanoclient
so table name has been passed which is
obviously a type string
you passed denmark dyna client which is
of type
you already know dynamo dpi face dot
dynamodb api
and you return multiple users
how do you run multiple users you return
basically a slice
of
users
wherein users is the struct that you've
defined right so you're using a struct
you're making a slice of all those users
and then that's what you're returning
i hope that makes sense
if you don't know basics of like of
course like slices and structs then i
highly recommend you check out the basic
tutorials before
you get more confused
so
um
i want to use a function by that
dynamodb gives me it's called
scan input
to get access to table name which is aws
dot
string
and
table name that we are already passing
here
got it
and you will say dynaclient
dot scan and you want to scan
the input the query that you just
created
right
so here as you saw
uh we had a more elaborate query because
we had to get a particular user with
email
but with fetch users you're just getting
all the users you don't have a specific
query that okay you know for this email
i get a particular user saying get me
all the users
so you don't have any query as such
you're just passing the table name so
that's when your dyna client.scan you
just pass the input that's it
and
scan is like get all you know you can
say that so if you've used
uh that mongodb it's you have find find
all something like that here you just
have scan
find and find one you have in mongodb so
you just have
scan all right
scan and get item so you're doing scan
to get all the results and you're going
to capture that in a variable called
result and then you'll obviously uh if
you have an error you know that standard
way to handle errors is like this
you'll say return
nail for the value and
you'll return an error so you'll say
errors dot new
error
failed to fetch record
and
again like we did out here
item
we'll define an item right
the item here is
not just a user it's a slice of users
multiple users because we're getting all
the users from our database
and
again the same thing that we've just
done here we'll do the same thing here
so we'll say error is equal to
just copy the whole thing actually
copy and paste
but there's only one small little change
instead of result.item
you'll have result dot
items
because obviously from your database
you'll get multiple items multiple users
that's what you're getting
and you're returning
your item
and for the error you're turning nil
makes sense
so
we've done quite a bit right we've
already done the get user function and
get user function had fetch user and
fetch users two functions from your
user.com file
now there are three functions left here
and
three functions left here because we've
already taken care of the unhandled
method function you don't have to do
anything more here so just three
functions left here three functions left
here
and all the other files are kind of
complete
right so if you've reached this far
congratulate yourself because
you've come you've come a long way
right
so now let's start thinking about
how our create user function is going to
work
all right
so for the create user function let's
let's start building that
there's actually not much happening
there
all these functions right uh create user
update user delegator
they're all going to look very very
similar so
i'm going to say user because you know
you want to call the create user
function the user package so you'll see
user dot
create user which is
this function that's what you're calling
right and you're passing it three things
request
table name plan a client makes sense
now whatever response
this function returns you want to
capture that in a variable called error
sorry result and you'll get an error
which will be captured in error
you know the process from here if
there's an error
which means error not equal to nil
you'll return
api response
http dot
status bad request comma
error body and what will be in the other
body everybody in this case by the way
is
sorry the struct that we've already
defined right
so what's there in the everybody it's
aws dot
string
with a single r sorry string
err dot error
and comma
okay
and you return api response
http dot status created
comma result
so if that means if there is no error
everything goes well then you'll say
http.start is created
all right
and
um
that's about it that's it actually
that's your create user function there's
nothing more to it
all right and then for your update user
function
very similar you'll
obviously call the user just like you
did here user dot create uh user here
you'll call user dot update user method
so you'll see
update user and you'll pass three things
request
table name and dynaclient
and
you'll capture that in result comma
header
and then you'll check again if error is
not equal to nil
you'll return an api response http dot
again
status bad request comma
error body inside the other body
again the same thing here is resource
string error dot
error
all right but if everything went well if
the user did get updated then
you'll return api response
and you'll say http dot
status okay
that everything went well and you'll
return the result
so that means what's happening in these
two functions creators and update user
is that
uh these two functions are being called
that means a lot of the logic the main
logic is going to happen in these two
functions right because not much
happened in the in the handlers
similarly let's work on our
delete user function here you'll say
user dot
read user you'll say request comma
table name comma
dyna client
here also
though
uh the only thing you'll run from here
is the error right
if
the user didn't get deleted you'll
return the error you don't need to
return the result any result from the
delete function
so
if the result is not equal to nil you'll
return api response
you know by now what we're going to say
we're going to say status bad request
and we're going to also send the error
body
which will have aws.string
[Music]
and
the error itself
but if everything went well you would
want to return
the response with
status okay
and
ultra nil
for the error
okay
so that's
um that's about it
and
um yeah that's it i think
the entire file is complete now
we don't have anything else to do
i've also gone through the aws sdk
documentation i don't think anything
else need to be done in the handler so
everything looks all right to me
and now we'll have to work on our
user.go file and all these different
functions that exist on our user.com
file
for your create user function
what all it's going to accept depends on
what you're sending from here which is
requestable even nanoclient
so here you'll say request
event start api gateway proxy request
comma table name which will be string
and
dyna client which will be you already
know the rmdbi face
dot nanometer api
so what is it going to return it's going
to return the user that has been just
created
or
an error
so here the first thing that we'll do is
we'll create a variable u which is of
type user user being the struct that
we've will define that means you will
have email first name and last name all
right
so let's start from there
now we'll use you
uh why did we create this variable you
it's because we want to capture what's
coming from
postman so from postman or from let's
say the terminal wherever we'll send the
json of the user with
the
email first name and last name and that
data needs to be unmarshaled into you so
that golang is able to understand it and
also perform any operations on it
so what you want to do is we want to use
the json encoding json package to call
the unmarshall
function
[Music]
and what you want to do is you want to
pass the request start body to it
comma ampersand you
[Music]
if error is not equal to nil
and also here
we'll follow the right syntax
for the if statement and if error is not
equivalent then we'll return
nil and we'll return something for the
errors
we'll say error
invalid
user data
but we don't have this error here right
so we don't have
uh this error error failure and marshall
record
we don't have error in value user data
we just have error fail to fetch record
that's all we have defined
so now let's define all the other errors
let me define all the other errors that
i'll need in this entire
file
in the beginning itself
so we'll say error
failed to
unmarshal record
is equal to
fail to unmarginal
record
and error run
and
i'll add
error and valid
user data is equal to
invalid
user data
invalid email also will be there and
valid
email is equal to
invalid email
then we'll have
good
not
marshall
item
and could not delete item so
then we'll have could not
put item so we'll say error
could not
dynamo put
item is equal to
code not dynamo put item
and
user already exists
user does
not exist
user.user
does not exist
so why do i need all these errors
obviously by now you would have
understood i'll just give you an example
that uh when creating
a user right
if we check if that user already exists
then we don't need to create that user
so that's why we need this kind of an
error
and if you want if you're updating a
user then or deleting a user we we can
use this that user does not exist so why
are you trying to update that user right
that's why um i'm just thinking about
all type of error functions i'll need
error statements i'll need so depending
on that i've just created them
so coming back to your create user
right
here
now we'll start validating
uh the email so we'll say
validators dot
validators is the package that we have
created together right this one
and the function that we created in that
package was is email
valid
and you is
the variable that you defined and now
after unmarshaling the request that you
in the body bodies of the request that
you got from let's say postman or from
the terminal as json
you captured that in you
so now you can now golang can easily
understand you because it's unmarked
right it's not json anymore so you can
access u dot email
and
uh you can run the validation function
on it so here the spelling is wrong
so it should have been
is email valid
and you'll return
nil comma
errors
dot new
error
invalid
email
right
and
now the reason why i created this
uh error is because
i want to
see if that user already exists
right so if that user already exists
then you don't need to create it so we
need to throw an error so we'll check
if the user already exists right so i
won't put that comment actually i was
just trying to show you
so
to check if the user actually exists you
have to run the fetch user function you
will say u dot email comma table name
comma diana client
and
you'll
capture whatever
comes from this function in current user
and we won't handle the error so i'll
put a
blank there
so if current user is not equal that
means there is uh this user exists right
if current user is not equal to nil and
length of
current user dot
email
is not equal to zero
then you return
nil comma
errors dot new
error
user already exists
and so all of this if the user exists
but if the user doesn't exist you will
just save that user right so how do you
save that so first to save that
obviously
whatever you now have in you you want to
start
going to start marshalling it right so
that dynode we can understand it now
so you'll say dynamodb
attribute dot
marshall map
you and you'll capture this in av
and you'll check for the error
so if there's an error we'll return nil
and errors dot new
error
could not
marshall
item
which we've already defined we've
already defined this error right
and
now
you want to start creating your
um
data that you will be sending to
dynamodb
so how would you do that you'll say
dynamodb
dot put
item input
item is av
comma
table name is aws dot
string table name
and finally you will say
dynaclient
dot put item
and you'll send
this input that you have defined here
sorry i just missed the is equal to sign
by mistake
similar to fetch users right you created
this input and then you call the dyna
client function similarly you're doing
that the same thing here you're calling
the put item
function and you'll capture that
in a blank character blank variable or
and or you'll get an editor from here
and if
error is there then you'll just handle
it very easily you'll say return l comma
headers
headers.new
header
good not
time output item right you have created
this error already
but if everything went well you just
want to return
the user
command
awesome
so this is your create user function
and now
you're
left with update user and delete user
everything else you've taken care of
right the handlers.go file is complete
api response is complete as as
email valid is complete and main.go is
complete
and i think for our user file we have uh
imported all the packages except for
validators so you need validators so
you'll say
github.com the validators package that
you've already created we talk i'm
talking about that one so we'll say go
serverless yt
slash pkg slash
validators
let me also check what else am i missing
for handlers i think i've already
imported user
and i don't need any more packages
for api response
um
i don't need more packages
for is email valid i don't need anything
else my main dot go file probably i
might have missed something so it has
handlers it has os
even slammed aws session dynamodb
dynamodb i face
so everything is proper based on the
aws sdk go right check out this
documentation you'll know why i'm
importing these uh packages and how i've
used these functions you already know
that because you've been building it
with me all right
um
then we'll come here again back to our
user.com file
and let's start working on the update
user function
so what does it accept accepts request
which is of type events
dot api gateway request comma table name
which is string comma
dyna client which is of type dynamodb i
face
dot dynamodb
api
returns a user the updated user
and
or i mean i mean r it sends back an
error
and we're going to do a lot of things
which are going to be very similar to
the create user function which is
basically we create the user
first we create the user right which is
the variable u which is our type user
and we're going to unmarshal
just like we did
we're going to unmarshal the
request our body that you get so request
dot
body
comma ampersand you
so by mistake
um yeah so i have to close the bracket
here because
this is together
and
this is this variable u
okay
and
here are not equal to nil
if you don't want to follow along you
can just copy and paste this part right
i'm not copying and pasting because uh
this syntax might be new to many people
because it's dynamic kind of working
with dynamodb
so i'm
writing everything by hand
but if you want to copy and paste if
you're very comfortable with dynamodb
go ahead and do that you don't need to
you know practice along with me
then you want to fetch the user and see
if that user even exists so you'll say
u.e mail comma table name comma
then a client
and you want to capture that in current
user
and you want to check for that current
user so
if current user
not equal to nil
this is exactly what you did in the
create
function as well
and length of
current user dot email
is equal to equal to zero
then you'll return nil comma
errors dot new
error
user does not exist
so for the create user function we were
checking uh for the user associated with
that email because we wanted to see you
know if that user only exists we don't
want to add that user but for update
we're doing the reverse we're checking
for that user because
only if that user exists we can update
the data for that user makes sense
and
exactly the same things we'll do because
now we want to start so now that the
user uh you know
um
if the user doesn't exist we'll throw an
error but if the user exists then you
want to start
updating
the table with the new data how do you
do that whatever you've unmarshaled
right now from json to uh you know and
marshall to something that golang
understands now you want to start
marshalling it to something that nobody
understands
so you already know what you want to use
you want to use the marshall map
function
i want to pass you to it because you
just unmarshaled
and
which package is a part of so it's part
of the dynamodb
attribute package
we'll capture it in a variable called av
or we'll get an error
and now we can easily handle the error
so we'll if error not equal to nil
return nil comma
errors dot new
error could not martial item this one
really really straightforward now you
just want to create your input item and
then you want to just call the dyna
client function
only two steps remaining so you'll say
input is equal to ampersand dyna
modb
dot put item input
and the item is
equal to av
comma the table name
will be equal to aws dot
string
table name
and the last thing is you'll use dyna
client
dot put item
and you'll pass the input
and if error not equal to nil
return nil comma
errors dot
new
error
could not dynam output item
return ampersand u comma nil
so now even my update function is
complete everything looks okay
and all i want to do now
is
um
run the
gomot id command
get all of the packages that
are
you know not there
so i think it's taking a while
i can't find my phone anyways
so
while that's happening in the background
we can start working on the delete user
function
so as you can see it's all
installed
i had a couple of issues actually
um as you can see
and most of the issues were because i
had a couple of spelling mistakes here
instead of sdk i did an skd you know so
a small small few mistakes i had made
just make sure you get these right um
you can easily get them on aws sdk go
um you know
documentation or if i put mostly i'll
put this code on github so you can just
pick it up from there
all right make sense
just pick it up from there instead of
typing it all yourself because i made a
couple of mistakes so it was taking a
while
but now it's installed all these
packages
so in your user.go file everything works
perfectly right
like we don't know if it works perfectly
but everything looks perfect to me
and all the packages are in place
all you need to do now
is work on your
read user function which is actually the
most
actually the like the easiest function
so it takes request
event start
api gateway request comma table name
which is of type string
done a client which is a type already
know you already know that
dot
dynamic api all right
so what do you want to put in the
function definition you want the email
of the user right
so request dot
query string parameters
and the parameters
email
then you'll create your input to the
function which is of type dynamodb
um
and dot
delete item input
item
input
star
dynamodb
dot attribute
value
[Applause]
basically you're passing the email and
then finding the user and deleting that
user with it associated to that
particular email right
nothing complicated
so you'll say aws dot
string
and you pass email to that
after this you'll say table name
aws dot string
pass the table name
and now that you have your input ready
just like we've done all other functions
you take the dyna client
you call the dynamodb function which is
delete item in this case
and you pass the input to it
input basically has your query for
deletion which is
the email id
and you get the error
and if there is an error
you'll return
errors dot new
error could not delete item
perfect
otherwise you just return nil nothing
basically that means that the user has
been deleted now i'm sure there are a
lot of errors
because i'm not using any
type checking
extension or any golang extension right
so there will be a lot of errors here
so i need to start solving them one by
one before i deploy it to the cloud
so to find those issues and to fix them
i'll head over to my terminal and i'll
head over to the cmd folder and i'll say
go build
main.go
and
starts giving me errors right so it says
on this file line number eight
um yeah i can see the issue it has to be
double right that's what makes it the
or operator
so
you'll run the command again and now you
will get all these nice
errors that we were expecting right and
now we want to go start solving them one
by one
so starting from line 37 all the way to
line 145 too many errors so when it says
too many errors that means that even
after you solve these it'll give you uh
many more errors right
so this is why i don't really you know
use
extensions because
because golang takes care of everything
it tells you which exact line which part
what you're missing you don't like it's
a no-brainer right you don't have to
apply a lot of brains just solve these
issues just like golang wants you to and
everything will run so that's why i'm so
chilled out all the time man
so if i go back to your code
on line 37 what could be the issue it's
that i have not put comma here and comma
here
basic syntax issues right that's what it
says it says basics index issues
here also you need to put a comma and
let's keep putting commas wherever you
know i think
uh
it will
uh need commas so this needs comma here
which is line 58 in my case you can
check it out where uh you know it is for
you
for create user again i'll just put a
comma here just to be sure
and i'll put a comma
in the input part which is
this
all right
and in the update user function
again let's go to the input
area
here i've put the commas so i don't see
any issues here
and for delete definitely you need to
put a comma here as well as here
as well as here so
now if we run it
a lot of the errors have gone away right
and now you have
some other errors there are some syntax
errors also like force index errors and
one
this one also that you're not able to
refer to this function so let's try and
fix those as well at the same time
so let's hover over back to our code
let me see the line first line says 88
line 88 blah blah blah blah blah yes
m is small whereas them should be large
what was i thinking am i stupid you know
that i was not able to
that i didn't make the m uh you know
large because obviously the
function is marshall map with
the capital m right so this just means
that no matter how stupid you are golang
takes care of everything right so you
don't need to be the smartest guy on the
planet
so let's look at other stupid mistakes
so 108
comma missing it's a syntax error super
simple right it's even telling you
expecting comma right i mean
how obvious can
error statements be and then people you
know tell me download this extension i
don't have downloaded an extension man
golang does everything for me
and missing statement after label 125
125
missing statement after label blah blah
blah blah blah yeah obviously
the is equal to sign is off
and then 147 147
put a comma here or after 147
and then
unexpected
yep
found it
now let's run it now let's see some more
errors
yes so it found us some more errors
and now you have to go to line number 66
76 and 140
but these are not
syntax errors so here you'll have to
think a little bit as to why there's an
error there
so head over back to your code on line
66
line 66
yeah so it says
let's look at the error it says
cannot use results dot disorder items
and something something something to do
with this function called unmarshall map
that is because you're receiving items
not item you're receiving multiple items
right so you can't use that marshall map
function here you'll just re use
unmarshall
list
of maps
super simple man super simple 76 line 76
all right it says blah blah blah blah
blah
request our body see it says request dot
body undefined
and it also says does not have body with
capital b
right
i mean you don't you can be the
stupidest person on the planet and fix
this issue because you just have to make
this be capital right
so that's how intuitive go language and
then you go to line number 140 line
number 140 i mean i can guarantee you
that you can't do any like something
like this with any other language right
it says there's a problem with this
function obviously because there's a
spelling mistake here
parameters so everything is fixed now
and now let's see
so it gives me another error that says
unmarginalist of map is wrong yeah
because i made a mistake again it should
have been
unmarginalist of maps
not map
awesome
so now
now that your user.go file is sorted as
in it first shows you the syntax errors
you've solved them then you solve the
logical errors and now it's giving you
some issues with the handlers file right
handler.go it's giving you all these
syntax errors we'll solve them and it'll
give us some
logical errors we'll solve them as well
and then we're good to go all right so
we're on the right path
and now let's go back to our code
so open up your code and start from line
19 line
19. put a comma here
line 42
for it to put a comma here it's because
saying it's accepting expecting a comma
from you right
and line 54
put a comma
line 59
blah blah blah blah blah blah comma
line 66 and 72 96 for a comma 72 comma
all right
now you start getting the real
errors right the real errors
so um line 22 we just solved this issue
on the other file line 22
because the spelling of parameters is
wrong
and now you want to worry about
uh line
nine
line nine
one thing you notice is that it's line 9
but of another file api response would
go so
open up the api smaller go file and here
i can see there's an issue
all right
i have fixed the issue it was basically
to do with
uh those brackets and now it's starting
to show me
issues with main.go file which is what i
want i want to fix the main.go file
issues but on line 44
line 44
let me see what's happening
okay yeah i can see it i can see the
issue it's basically
all the cases have to be together
and by mistake i'd written this outside
the bracket
also the switch bracket
and i've included inside
so that error should also go away
and now when i do this it's created the
go build may not go file for me so let
me see if it has yeah i can see the main
file i just have to
move it here
to my build folder
and i've created the build file without
any issues no errors right
so now let's start
uh the deployment process
before you do anything else you need to
first create
a zip file
so you'll just
come here you'll say zip minus jrm
build
slash main.zip
from build
slash main
so build is your folder main is the
build that you've created for in your
folder and
build slash main.zip will be the zip
file using the zip function maybe in
your linux you don't have zip you'll
have to install it using sudo apt-get
install zip
so
now if we check here
we can see the main.js file in my build
folder
and now we're ready to kind of start
uploading it on lambda or aws lambda
but as remember as you remember i told
you that i have windows installed on
that i'm running wsl on that i'm running
this
ubuntu and on top of that i've built
this uh folder right so i need to be
able to access this main.zip file from
my
uh windows
from my windows to be able to install
like upload it on my here plus school
and lambda aws lambda
dashboard so
for that i'll do something
[Music]
so to in order to help me to do that i
have to run
this command explorer.exe
dot
and now hopefully it should open yeah it
has it has opened up the
explorer at this location for me and
i'll copy this
i'll put this on my desktop
awesome
and now i can start to deploy this on my
aws console
so you want to start deploying
but there's one thing i wanted to change
is this
table name
so i'll keep this table name same as my
the name of my
program
go serverless yt
okay just for consistency's sake because
we'll have to create this table in
dynamodb
and
let me just search
uh if i was using the other table name
sorry i'll just ctrl z
and i'll just see if i was using this
table name anywhere else in any other
file
oh it's this only place there's only one
place i was using it
so here's the table name has to be
changed
you will say go serverless righty
okay
and now is when we start deploying so
log into your console
and head over to lambda you have to just
create function
go
serverless
ready
so we're using google lang 1.x i think
we'll have to change the
uh
execution roles create new role
from aws policy templates this option is
what you have to select
and the role name
go
serverless
righty
executor
from the templates you have to choose
simple microservice permissions create
function
successfully created right
now you want to
change the handler
so as you know our main uh the file that
we'll be uploading is called the main
file that's what our build is called
right so we'll have to change the
handler to main upload
the zip file and upload it go back to
aws
and go to dynamodb
and you will click on
create table
table name so table name is what you
selected here go server syt
simple right because we have kept
everything
with the same name so
and primary key so it says enter the
partition key name i think this is the
primary key
yeah it's the primary key so the primary
in our case is email
which is string obviously
and everything else is same and we can
just create the database active it's now
active so now we can proceed to the next
stage
which is
configuring your
api gateway
so head over to your api gateway
create api
you want to build a rest api
protocol is test
select new api here
and now you want to put the api name
which is go
serverless
id
and
you then create the api
from the actions
select create method
select any
and here you'll select integration type
lambda function
and
check this use lambda proxy integration
and give the name of the lambda function
here which is
go serverless yt
and you have to also have to ensure this
is checked default timeout
now we need to deploy our api so
from actions
deploy api
select new stage
stage name is staging
and
deploy
so this is
your url that you get here
which you'll be using right now to
test
so let's test it out i'm
expecting some errors to be there
but not a problem
let's clear our screen
and
um
first we'll have to build this command
so just give me a second
so here are my four commands
and obviously uh this is
post which is creating a user this is
get all users get a particular user by
email id
and this last command is for update
now we can use postman or you can you
just use curl which is the same thing
right and you set your header and you
tell it what's the request which is post
and the data that you need to send which
is email which is my email address my
name my last name
and
this is the the unique link that i just
got
this uh link is the unique link that i
just got
from my
invoke url okay so i'll post these comma
i'll post this command somewhere how do
i post it now okay so i'll what i'll do
is i'll upload this project on github
and then in the description i think i'll
just post these commands so that you
know you can just copy and paste them
directly
uh i think that'll be the best option or
you can just use post manual and you
don't you have to use these commands if
you don't want to all right
and similarly for
the update
you say it's request put you give the
new data it's going to find email based
on that because emails are primary key
as you already know
and this is my api link
these are the four commands i need one
more command which is
the
delete command
so i'll change that
to this
so you'll get all these in the um
an api gateway documentation on how to
uh call these apis you can get that also
and so i'm just copying those and i'm
just changing
uh those commands all right
so what we'll do now is we'll try and
test it
i'm pretty sure there'll be some error
it'll fail
but
let's do it anyway
oh so it worked it worked all right so
it created this user
which is amazing
let's run the second command
sorry this command
i don't know now it's not copying you
pasting it
now we're running the get all users
command
so we'll get all the users so only one
user is there so it's getting that
and then we'll get the particular user
the particular user has this email id
it will get that user also for me
because there's only one user right now
yeah so that's also working and now
we'll work on our
put
function so
it's taking my
email address and changing my first name
to la la la and last time to blah blah
blah blah blah right so it's done that
so even update is working
and now we have to work on
the delete function
so if the delete function works
it won't
return anything so we'll check
if that user is still there so we're
getting all the users
so that means delete work because it's
an empty array right the same user is
not there anymore
perfect
so that means everything is working i
hope you enjoyed uh this tutorial
uh it's a it's a long video i know
there's a lot to follow there's a lot to
learn there and i hope you really
enjoyed it i hope you learned a lot in
this uh
project
and um very soon i'll have i'll have one
more project coming up with serverless
stack but it's a little more advanced
we'll have multiple lambda functions
we'll have cloud formation we'll have
you know those cloud formation scripts
so and everything will be through
uh you know yaml files and then aws cli
and we'll also use aws sam for the
entire setup so that's going to be
really complicated um so make sure
you've done the aws lambda uh you know
that video and you have done this
serverless video and then you read up a
little bit more about how ls works and
all the aws technologies and that will
really help you in the next uh upcoming
video they'll be slightly longer
actually much longer and they'll have
like way more complicated project right
so the point of that is where this is
like a monolith serverless project right
that will be serverless microservices
project there will be api gateway cloud
formation
uh there will be a lot more technologies
i will use plus sam for all the writing
all the
configuration files
anyhow so i hope you're enjoying it and
do subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already and there are hundreds
of videos on golang on my channel check
them out and i also keep sharing some
nice advice on
you know
your development career so you keep
watching that as well
all right so see you
and connect with me on linkedin there's
the linkedin link in my description box
below thank you